[Music]
and disrespectful do snooze you do
disrespectful once dad submitted by
Peter taught Oh give me some of your
tots
I love tater tots Malaysian students
sparked outrage after pooping in the
showers at a popular Lodge in Japan they
pooped in the shower Malaysian students
and like they've almost stopped it I
don't know what they did to it and they
did in Japan in Japan in Japan the
cleanest place in the world why would
you do that
you have no [ __ ] electronics I'm right
next to you they're probably like sings
32 different songs yeah shower you don't
ask did they mistake the Malaysian for a
Chinese and Malaysians are so respectful
what the [ __ ] well according to this
lodge it's called vide lodge this a
guest house in Osaka they're saying that
they've had pretty bad experiences with
Malaysian Oh Malaysia this is like kind
of like their last straw so they ended a
banning Malaysian old Oh deleted that
post so it seems I think it took the ban
back yeah so what happened was there
were these three students Malaysian
students they were visiting Osaka and
they were staying at this guesthouse and
apparently they they had missed their
flight home and so they needed to buy a
new ticket and so they asked them if
they could stay another two nights at
the lodge and so the owner she was
really nice and they were like yeah sure
you know go ahead but then apparently
some should happen and one thing led to
another and these students ended up
getting into some sort of altercation
with the lodge manager yeah and they
started arguing with each other and then
that led to them getting kicked out and
right before they left they pooped in
the shower I know I know I know this
story because um I helped you pick the
article and I remember reading it
because they're actually not Japanese
people uh they're like Indian or
something they owned a house out there
that owned a lodge in Japan and the
reason why they let the Malaysian guys
stay like a couple days after is because
they're both Muslims so they're like
under you know because we're both men
bite like brothers under the same
religion I'm gonna help you guys out so
as a favor he helped them out
let him stay for two days but because of
that argument or whatever they got
happen they they turned around and took
a dump that's so rude yeah yeah
apparently what the reason why they
using Muslim where the night either no
there's only identifies because these
these students they ended up using the
kitchen or they were cooking past the
certain time which is against the rules
and then that's when it led to shooting
and that's when it led to them getting
into a verbal education which led them
to poop in the shower
hey it's past 10 p.m. but they have jet
lag oh and of all things why would you
set all together on pooping in the
shower yeah you could have set the house
on fire
you could have [ __ ] graffiti'd on the
walls what are we good what are we gonna
do here what are we gonna do should we
should we burn this place down nah he
let us stay for two days how about this
all three of us take a dump in the tub
right that'll show them what's up maybe
it's super disrespectful they're like
I'm thinking Malaysia or Muslims or that
pooping in the shower is like the worst
disrespectfully to someone yeah but
these are the student and so what I mean
it's at least I did [ __ ] on the bed cuz
I mean in the in the in the shower you
could just rinse it use kind of [ __ ] sit
there like for the longest time breaking
down the shell just grab a little like
like sand shovel just a spatula
right dog [ __ ] with your hands all it's
not with just your hands you love your
children with your bare hands
Buller scooper that's nice
Lysol everything you're good to go yeah
so that post that I mentioned earlier
about them like Fanny Malaysians the
translated message read to all
Malaysians who are visiting Japan shower
rooms are only used for taking showers
and washing your body you can't poop in
it parentheses don't [ __ ] in the shower
room be polite and give a good picture
about Malaysian Malaysia and your people
this is the third time this has happened
in our kids maybe their service is
probably [ __ ] up but fighting and
they're like okay I'm gonna give you a
poopie I didn't want to settle Asians so
there's something about Malaysia we're
pooping in the shower is probably the
worst insult because there's three three
now because now it's like come on like
people keep coming to you and then you
end up with the same maybe it's
something going on or maybe maybe it's
an inside joke where's the best it's a
destination now where everyone knows we
got to go there and poop in the bugger
shower take photo selfies taking a
traditional [ __ ] in the shower
those guys I'm actually curious what
Koreans and mainland Chinese guests did
because apparently they are blacklisted
Francis you see it's the piss - it can't
be every single one every single race
come on if everyone else around you is
an [ __ ] that means you're an [ __ ]
you know I just want to know why
Indians owned hotels everywhere
that's like Vietnamese people with the
nail thing like who yeah was the Indian
that started it like I'm gonna open up a
motel here in the middle of the desert
where there's no other Indians I know a
Vietnamese people it was goddamn I don't
know who it was but she was a very she
was an American that pretty much like
connected with the Vietnamese refugees
at the time okay she's I'm gonna teach
you how to do some [ __ ] yeah she's
like you know what these people have
nothing like this comes his country they
have nothing she was like a wife of like
someone very like a president not a
prize
someone someone in the government or
some [ __ ] or another and um she was like
she really connected with these people
like they showed her like their food and
stuff she's like I got to teach him
something you teach me egg rolls i'ma
teach you nails yeah so she wants to
help them so she's like you know what
there's a nail school whatever that may
be she had or like she knew someone the
nail school and she brought them there
to teach him everything that's pretty
much how it all started like back during
the donut shop in Cambodian ya know
they're [ __ ] own I only know my people
yeah I don't I don't know if they're
Indian I'm just making this up I don't
know either they're just they're just
Brown it could be a Pakistani they're a
Muslim yeah they just say under the
Brotherhood of the Muslims I must help
you out brother Muslim people their
religion they're supposed to be very
welcoming and hospitable well so maybe
it was that but then huh
and then you just that's mean mad that's
when net medicines found out about this
story and they started saying especially
Malaysians are like oh you know we
apologize on behalf of all Malaysians we
were not all like that
yeah and then they're just I personally
been to Malaysia two times and never saw
Dookie in the shower ever
it would be all nice nice very very very
nice go to Malaysia very nice it's fun
it is very fun everyone's super cool and
we have a lot of fans there and I'm
pretty sure they're not [ __ ] in the
show oh we love Malaysia it's a clean
place it's gonna go over there be like
do I do the traditional poopy in a
shower do I take a picture and send it
to make sure that you guys know that I
did it a traditional Finnish boy started
getting a [ __ ]
the shower done yeah and so they just
got a lot of hate and so that's when
vidi Lodge
they ended up uploading one of the
apologies from one of the boys and like
this eight minute long video and so they
were just saying like telling other
people like stop bashing on the boys
we've already forgiven them we lifted
the ban on Malaysians after they
apologized so let's move forward kind of
thing What did he say I made a mistake
I'm not sure I should have never took a
dump on the shower how do you explain
yourself I was an act of anger it was
just i I wasn't thinking it just came
out it wasn't me it was me yeah in the
spur of the moment I just decided to
take a dump like never in my life have I
ever been so pissed at someone that I
want to poop in somebody they belong in
yeah I wonder what kind of dog he was
was like a wet Dookie or was it like one
that just could make a swirl or is it
like a log like what are like a dried
Gravatt pellet oh you take a [ __ ] in
like a heat at a moment like yeah okay
so the guy that goes first
clearly it's a clean shower there's
three scoops of poop alright and the
last guy that goes in he has to smell
the other two poops you know like who
like did they Rochambeau
and there's like a poop harmony in there
that's messed up too because not a lot
of people know like Malaysia or heard of
the country and all that stuff or even
saw the Malaysian poop before
yeah and so when this news goes out
people are gonna be like oh they're the
poopy people they're the shower Cooper's
is the shower three people who people
know they go to hotels and take a dump
in showers be careful those Malaysia's
in the shower
I know let them in your showers give
them a room without a shower that's the
way they won't do it in bathtubs or
showers so are the are the boys getting
like beat up and bullied now cuz like
hey poopy yeah you make our country
looked at ya know the rest of us peace
were shower shooters that should have
been the title the shower shoes
professional team Malaysian shower
shooters I don't know someone if you had
a guest come over and they did this in
your home what would you do
oh dude like I have their information
you mean like are they still in my house
yeah are they still in or left oh they
like was it by x-column back yeah I
wouldn't let them stay any I call them
back I'd be like hey I think you forgot
something
why did you do that up I asked them
because most people things most people
we let stay in our place we're pretty
close with them so I can't really see
that happening but if they did I
probably like immediately text them and
I go wide to do that so I remember one
of my friends back in a day we were all
doing a little bit of ecstasy and he
decided that he needed to go poopy so he
was in the restroom for a long time and
we were just like dude like do you think
fast and [ __ ]
ecstasy poops lasts a long time yeah so
I was knocking on the door as it feels
awesome he was like I was like are you
okay go use it yeah yeah yeah I'm okay
and I hear like the like he's trying to
flush it and I'm like okay and then like
some more time comes in and I'm like hey
are you sure you're okay he's like yeah
ha ha um don't get mad okay and I'm like
why would I get mad he's like I need
help and I'm like oh [ __ ]
I thought he was like dying and [ __ ] so
I got my other friend like Robert come
here I think I think he's in trouble so
like we hope he opens up the door right
huh he's puttin it
no he opened so so the door he opens up
the door there's like a centimeter of
water all over the floor
yeah and there's [ __ ] all over my
bathroom floor and
he has his pants like hanging on my on
my shower theme so he's just in his
underwear with a t-shirt and he has that
hanging and yeah and he's got like
tissue like that and he's picking up
Dookie putting it back into the toilet
was the water cloudy - the water chip
like who's a [ __ ] fountain so the bull
the ball was like overflowing and then
you know how like it keeps leaking right
so it just keeps going and we're like oh
[ __ ]
so we're like trying to get the Dookie
and we're throwing it back in and Hawley
we're cracking up and he's so
embarrassed at that times like don't get
bad don't get bad don't get bad and I'm
like two people what are three people
together one guys in the like one guys
this shitty buddy's in his and if his
underwear was like tighty whities I hope
hasn't married yet I don't know I've had
a contact with the beanie boy his
wedding until that story but it was the
funniest [ __ ] ever like yeah wash your
hands because you're rubbing your eyes
right what ended up happening was she
kept she had one of those shits he said
that that he had to keep wiping and
wiping and wiping he kept throwing paper
sheet marks yeah so he filled it up with
paper and by the time he flushed it got
stuck and then there wasn't that plunger
thing so he tried to put more paper
inside yeah flooded it even more and
then it got to the point where it was
like uncontrollable and you didn't know
what to do the water shut off the valve
oh yeah he was he was rolling really
hard yeah yes I learned you turn that
[ __ ] off or if you have like a big poop
that got stuck you go boil some water
giving it's in your house and out your
necks Liam Bolling water or someone
else's house but you go boil some water
and you pour
because it melts the fats in the poops
and then it breaks oh no I mean all I
did was take the plunger in and pop yeah
and it broke it up and flushed itself
poor guy I would die of embarrassment
especially rolling [ __ ] that's a
terrible rule I don't know but we were
we were cleaning and laughing like
you're a good friend from hey guys
thanks for watching if you guys enjoy
that episode please let us know in the
comments below and share your thoughts I
like this so much oh I wish they talked
about this and this just let us know in
the comments for more videos click right
up here